we are so excited to come back to make  more fun more mood boards and more  heartwarming moments right here on our  show and we want to hear from you what  you want to see next season and you've  actually been kind enough to tell us  this comes from victoria from san  francisco california  keep your stylist your outfits are  perfect victoria i've actually been  lucky enough to work with none other  than lee harris for over how long has it  been lee 25 years  that's right  um and on our show's instagram you can  actually see our outfit of the day  we have posts and then we show you how  to shop the look so that you can get  something similar for yourself if that's  of interest to you but thank you again  victoria i'm glad you like the look  thank you lee harris  [Music]